so I recently had the pleasure of
hanging out with Olympic skier Devin
Logan we actually jumped around on
trampolines and we fling flung ourselves
flung ourselves and do foam hits scrape
take a look instead of me explaining
keep rolling isn't it more important
that we feel like champions in our
hearts yeah but it feel better to have
some bling around your neck too yeah
well she actually did it and here she is
Olympic silver medalist Kevin Love
everybody
I know right he looks so lovely last I
saw you we were both in like kind of our
sweat gear and no way now you class up
nicely do you see what this thing does
to me now yeah totally do you ever just
wear it out yeah I get a lot of free
things from this really yeah you flash
it around it's kind of like a platinum
card but it's a platinum disc yeah I'm
like four four four I'm free dinners if
you could get a free meal at any
restaurant what's your go-to cuz you're
pretty chill I don't see you in like you
know like a fancy pantsy place um we I
was trying to get it at McDonald's cuz
in in the athlete village we didn't have
the free McDonald's up there and I was
really bummed why is that something they
normally have yeah there is that in the
coastal village I don't know why they
didn't have it in the mountain village
Sochi so cheap so cheap she said it will
work on that if we if we go back to
Russia I'll make a few phone calls I'll
be like I gotta have their quarter
pounders or whatever you call it with
your you know Russian math yeah Ripple's
Boop rubles yeah I don't like a
backwards R it makes me uncomfortable
I feel like Tetris pieces are gonna
start falling gonna happen that's a joke
from 1982 have you considered melting
the metal down in fear of werewolves
no I think this would be a great weapon
though do you have you fell out heaven
no I would love to feel that that's
heavier than I'd like they didn't give
it a lot of thought I mean it looks
great but this is look at this look at
how that's why you're uncomfortable hey
Devin are you doing oh my god one just
drop it how much do you think are kind
of loose you know I was like a funny guy
that came in and loosened you up on the
we tramped it up you go eating me
up I loosened you up how much is that do
you think helped you win a silver medal
this would be a good time to let America
know um America I would not be here with
the silver medal if it wasn't for this
man right next me you taught me every
trick I know I tell you every trick
every trick what is your coach's name
scogan suck it scogan